all right ted well gamestop is now the
latest battleground between financial
elite
and actually small investors because
shares of this company soared
nearly 800 percent over the past week
kirsten joyce has been keeping an eye on
those numbers she joins us now with the
details and also reaction from a local
man
who made some money in a pretty similar
fashion
kirsten that's right denise
here's what happened all of last year
gamestop was apparently struggling
big wall street investors saw an
opportunity
they started shorting the stock betting
it would drop
well then that action angered the small
investors who use
social media and apps encouraging others
to buy
creating massive losses for those big
time investors
well the same happened when movie
theater chain amc
saw its stock surge more than 300
percent
just this wednesday after the hashtag
save amc began trending on twitter
las vegas resident danny silva says he
watched as people then took their game
stock profits and moved them to amc
i was able to ride amc all the way up i
scalped in and out of it which
was means you sell early sometimes in
the morning when it's higher
and then you get back in when it's lower
in the day i did that a few times and i
wrote it up and i was able to make some
money on it myself which is i'm pretty
happy about
silva says he's pretty new at day
trading he started last may when he was
furloughed from his job and needed to
make some extra income
he says it's a commitment if you're
going to do it yourself because
you constantly have to watch it and i
still don't have a great idea what i'm
doing but i'm following these uh
social media experts that are making
these great calls and we're
some of them are really paying off
still the experts say the best way to
invest in the stock market is to either
work with a financial advisor or
retirement portfolio manager and if you
do see a stock that
you're interested in they say do the
research and buy essentially
on the fundamentals denise